[Music]
spider-man no way home may be the most
secretive movie in the marvel cinematic
universe since avengers end game for
months it's been surrounded by rumors of
returning spider-man from different
timelines villainous resurrections and
more multiversal shenanigans than you
could shake a time stone at star tom
holland told variety his third outing as
the famous web slinger is going to be
the most ambitious standalone superhero
movie ever made and so far it's shaping
up to be just that here's everything we
know about the release date cast and
plot of spider-man no way home
what just happened
let's start with something we do know
for sure spider-man no way home is set
to debut in theaters on december 17
2021. when it comes to the film's future
on at-home streaming services though
things get a little more complicated if
you're an mcu or disney fan you've
likely already taken advantage of the
fact that the studios have been
releasing some of their most hotly
anticipated blockbusters on disney plus
during the covet 19 pandemic it would
make sense for no way home to follow
suit except that the spider-man movies
are actually sony properties and the
fact that the character was introduced
into the mcu at all is kind of a
business deal miracle that deal means we
get to see holland's peter parker
palling around with the likes of doctor
strange but it also means that you won't
be seeing the movie on disney plus
premiere access that's the bad news the
good news is that this is probably the
only mcu movie where tom hardy's venom
just might show up according to what's
on disney plus no way home will be
heading to stars after its theatrical
and home video runs while it will
eventually find its way to the disney
plus library that won't be happening
anytime soon if you want to see no way
home when it premieres on december 17th
you're going to have to mask up and head
to the theater
disinfect the mask
when it comes to the cast for spider-man
no way home there are some things we can
be sure of tom holland is definitely
back as peter parker zendaya will
reprise her role as mj jacob battle on
will return as ned and marisa tomei will
once again play aunt may additionally we
know that there will be several
crossovers with the established mcu dr
strange's benedict cumberbatch and
benedict wong will be making appearances
while perennial mcu ensemble member john
favreau will once again play happy hogan
poppies are you is it me yeah of course
it's me now for the really fun stuff as
has been speculated for some time there
will be returning characters from sam
raimi's spider-man trilogy and the two
amazing spider-man films from mark webb
the no way home trailer gave us a
glimpse of alfred molina as otto
octavius aka dr octopus aka doc ock and
with the november 16th release of the
final trailer we can now say for sure
that jamie foxx's max dillon aka electro
and willem dafoe's iconic green goblin
are returning to the big screen
you know how much i sacrificed the
trailer also showed us that the amazing
spider-man series lizard and spider-man
3's sandman are making a sinister return
as well jk simmons who popped up in the
mid-credit sequence of spider-man far
from home will also be returning as jay
jonah jameson i want spider-man
the biggest question that's been
surrounding no way home is whether any
of the previous spider-men toby maguire
and andrew garfield will be featured in
the film
everyone from holland to garfield to
kevin feige himself has thrown cold
water on those rumors but we know better
this multiversal crossover is almost
definitely happening and even if we
don't get any official word on their
appearance they pretty much have to be
there or fans will revolt you have to
remember just stay calm
as far as the plot for spider-man no way
home is concerned there's a lot we do
know but even more we don't know based
on the trailer and the official bits of
synopsis that have come out we know that
the film will see peter parker dealing
with the aftermath of the mid-credit
sequence from far from home where
jameson played a video from quentin beck
aka mysterio revealing to the world that
the plucky high schooler is in fact
spider-man when the pressure of this
revelation gets to be too much for him
peter goes to his old buddy dr strange
to have him perform a little timeline
magic and zap everything back to before
his identity was doxed but of course
that doesn't exactly go as planned the
trailer's world bending action and the
presence of villains from the previous
film series suggest that no way home
will see peter and his allies dealing
with a total multiverse meltdown of
course exactly what that entails will be
revealed when we see the movie itself
considering this is the last movie in
holland's spider-man trilogy though it's
safe to say that the stakes will be huge
spider-man no way home hits theaters on
december 17th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]